justice department will not tolerate
attempts by any foreign power the United
States has accused China of meddling
into its domestic affairs to aspire's
wash
[Music]
room
we will continue to fiercely protect the
rights guaranteed to everyone in our
country and we will defend the Integrity
of our institutions
have you ever heard of a company called
it Huawei inside the U.S you probably
haven't heard them unless you're a tech
Enthusiast but outside the US and
especially in Asia they're ginormous
in fact a few years ago they overtook
apple and it became the world's second
largest smartphone seller only beaten
out by Samsung and during the pandemic
they further their lead by overtaking
Samsung as well while this is awesome
for Huawei and China it may not be all
that great for the rest of us
if you've been following international
news you probably know that Huawei has a
sketchy past when it comes to
surveillance and a data collection
now this is nothing new again that
basically every tech company does this
but there's one key difference between
most tech companies and Huawei
most tech companies collect your data to
craft effective marketing campaigns and
to sell you stuff
conversely Huawei allegedly collects
your data for the Chinese Communist
party in fact in 2019 the US actually
outright banned Huawei in the country
since then tensions had been cooling
down and Huawei was getting a break but
more recently the pendulum has swung in
the other direction once again
in late 2022 the U.S charged two Chinese
Intelligence Officers for trying to
steal data regarding the case against
Huawei technically we don't know if this
case has to do with Huawei
the U.S only disclosed that it had to do
with a large Chinese telecommunications
company but it's assumed that they're
probably talking about Huawei and it's
not just court cases that they're
apparently spying on either
the U.S accuses that China is using
Huawei to also spy on radio
communications for military bases
missile silos and who knows what else
and with Huawei becoming the largest
smartphone producer in the world this
threat is only growing larger by the day
so here's how Huawei Rose to overtake
Samsung and Apple and how they could be
using their market share to spawn the
world for China
foreign
taking a look back the story of Huawei
dates back to September of 1987 to a man
named Iran Zhang FEI at the time China
was desperately trying to develop their
technology and economy for the past few
decades China had fallen quite behind it
due to internal conflicts and the
Communist Revolution
but moving into the 1980s China wanted
to change that by embracing the free
market to a degree
one of these efforts centered on trying
to develop China's telecommunications
infrastructure Rana a former deputy
director of The People's Liberation Army
engineering corpse was familiar with the
effort and decided to Leverage The
Situation
he got together a couple of investors
and raised a total of five thousand
dollars to start Huawei you might be
thinking that five thousand dollars
isn't all that much money especially to
develop new telecommunications
technology and you'd be right the point
to note though is that Ren had no
intention of developing anything himself
instead his plan was to acquire foreign
Tech and reverse engineer it using local
researchers and when I say reverse
engineer I don't mean trying to
understand the tech and the creating
something new I mean blatantly ripping
off competitors and the creating
counterfeits Ren's first Target was a
new telecommunication startup called
Qualcomm you may have heard of them
it turned out that trying to copy
technology itself took quite a bit of
time so to start bringing in some
Revenue Ren started to resell private
Branch exchange or PBX switches that he
imported from Hong Kong this Revenue
allowed the company to grow their
reverse engineering team substantially
up to 600 people in terms of a company
name it Ren simply settled on a slogan
that would play well with the public the
original slogan was zhongwa uwei which
means China has promised we're gonna
altered this to Huawei or as it's
properly pronounced Huawei which
translates to China is able the CCP was
likely fans of this name but that's not
the only thing that attracted them to
Huawei by 1993 the company would
successfully create their own telephones
which knockoff which was magnitudes
better than anything else in China
Huawei turned around and deployed these
switches across small cities and rural
areas where there wasn't much
competition from the existing players
but likely their biggest and smartest
move was partnering with the people's
Liberation Army in terms of Revenue this
wasn't all that lucrative but in terms
of connections and influence this deal
was insane The Story Goes that when Ren
was pitching the CCP on the telephone
switch he told them quote switching
Equipment Technology was related to
National Security and that a nation that
did not have its own switching equipment
was like one that lacked its own
military reportedly the CCP official
agreed it but if that's the case why in
the world is Huawei trying to get other
countries to use their
telecommunications equipment yeah I
think you can see where this is going
it appears that China truly did believe
in rent's statement as they would triple
down on Huawei and domestic switches
in fact 1996 China adopted an explicit
policy that supported domestic
manufacturing and restricted access to
foreign options
given that Huawei was the only Chinese
company that was producing equipment
that was comparable to foreign
counterparts Huawei became the go-to
company for both the government and the
military
they weren't just making strides within
China either
starting in the late 1990s Huawei would
aggressively expand to developing
countries in sub-Saharan Africa and the
Middle East
these countries were easy targets given
that most of them could not afford a
western options
so there was really only two options
either they take help from the Chinese
or they put off development
obviously they went with the first
option what's surprising though is that
Western countries would soon jump onto
the Huawei bandwagon as well one of the
first countries to follow was Canada
when their Telecom giant Nortel
outsourced their entire production and
Engineering to Huawei it appears that
higher profit margins was simply
something that many Western companies
couldn't turn down
don't be fooled though switching to
Huawei was usually a terrible choice and
it's not some sort of conspiracy theory
as it's usually blatantly obvious though
Huawei of course always denies
everything take Nortel for example
shortly after making a deal with Huawei
Chinese hackers would begin stealing
hundreds of sensitive internal documents
from nortel for a period of at least 10
years according to Huawei this hacking
has nothing to do with them but you can
take that for what you will to make
things worse it wasn't just North tell
that Huawei was allegedly spying on
Huawei may have gained access to
Canada's National Defense through Nortel
reportedly listening devices were found
in nortel's Ottawa r d complex
this complex worked extremely closely
with Canada's National Defense so much
so that after Nortel filed for
bankruptcy largely due to corporate
Espionage this building would become
Canada's National Defense HQ for obvious
reasons Canada isn't letting Huawei come
anywhere near their 5G networks Canada
wasn't the only country to learn the
hard way either around the same time the
north Alessandra dealed Huawei dozens of
Western companies were also assigning
deals with Huawei at first this started
off with background players like UK's
Vodafone Australia's Optus Norway's
tanor and Japan's Panasonic but this
quickly grew to Encompass all of the
American Giants as well including Google
Facebook Qualcomm Intel and Microsoft
since then it each and every one of the
companies that I just listed have cut
their ties with Huawei either due to
getting burned themselves or due to
government Bans
so fortunately it looks like companies
and countries started rising up to
Huawei in the late 2010s but this didn't
matter all that much given that Huawei
had already shifted to a completely
different ball game
from the very beginning Huawei knew that
the end game was to reach end users they
couldn't quite do this from the very
beginning given that creating consumer
Tech and reaching Everyday People is
expensive but thanks to all these
contracts with companies and the
governments Huawei was able to
infiltrate the consumer market and given
that they were a telecommunications
company their product was obviously cell
phones Huawei didn't actually start out
with smartphones in fact their first
cell phone the C300 came out way back in
2003 they followed this up with a 3G
phone called the eu626 and a 3G handset
called the v710 these products performed
all right in China and some parts of
Europe but huawei's breakthrough didn't
come until the introduction of
smartphones which they were perfectly
positioned for they were already in the
Telecommunications Market they were
already in the cell phone market they
had to fall back in from the CCP and
they also had an international presence
on top of this the company was mature
enough where they didn't have to
directly copy competitors
instead they could take inspiration and
incorporate their own twist which is
exactly what they did with the UI 8220
in 2009
since then Huawei has become a leader
when it comes to incorporating the
latest networks cameras charging and
even designs
and the reason that their smartphones
are so popular isn't rocket science they
make great phones that are usually
cheaper than the competition it's that
simple and today they regularly ship
more than 200 million phones every
single year
I don't think you'd be surprised here
that they've expanded to selling much
more than smartphones either they've got
laptops tablets watches and even a car
so Huawei isn't going anywhere anytime
soon but what does this mean for all of
us well whether Huawei wants to admit it
or not they're likely going to spy on it
and surveil as many people as they can
many people who buy Huawei products are
well aware of this but they don't really
care they usually figure that even if
it's not a Huawei that's spying on them
it'll be companies like Google Facebook
and Oracle so they might as well forget
about trying to protect their privacy
and instead just focus on buying the
best product for the best price so that
answers the consumer side of things but
what about huawei's side of things why
in the first place
foreign
Huawei is extraordinarily popular so why
resort to allegedly is buying for the
CCP at the end of the day they are a
hardware company not a software company
so they shouldn't need to collect data
right well the answer is that they have
no choice it was the CCP who made Huawei
into who they are today and the CCP can
bring back Huawei to xero if they wanted
to and if you don't believe me just look
at Jack ma Alibaba and the Ant group
over the years the CCP has provided
Huawei with 46 billion loans along with
25 billion dollars in tax cuts and who
knows how much revenue the CCP has
brought Huawei in the form of government
contracts also we should note that this
has always been a one-sided relationship
while Huawei is dependent on the CCP the
CCP is not dependent on Huawei the CCP
did not put all of their eggs in one
basket as they also have giants like
tensioned jd.com Alibaba Tick Tock and
the entirety of the Chinese Financial
system
so China basically owns Huawei and
Huawei has to do what the CCP says
regardless of how that will affect their
own reputation or Public Image looking
forward what countries are doing their
best to hamper huawei's influence and
it's not easy to mitigate the control
you get from having access to billions
of users and the Decades of
telecommunications infrastructure and
given that most consumers just see
Huawei as another Facebook or Google
it's unlikely that we'll see much
resistance from the general public
either
so it's safe to say that Huawei won't
have much trouble maintaining their
dominance and allegedly reporting their
findings to the CCP would you rather
give your data to Huawei or Facebook
comment that down below also drop a like
if this video gave you more insight into
the Huawei bands and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community such
as future video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions that
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one
foreign